I've worked my ass off to get where I am
today like I've been working grinding
since I was 12 years old and been
through hell and back to get where I am
today
I do really dumb like dad jokes that's
my whole thing they do well I think
everyone on the internet kind of knows
them I'm like the dad of the house like
everyone knows that I just do take
talking stuff because it's fun I'm not a
tick talker I'm not a youtuber I'm not
an instagramer
I'm an entrepreneur and a business
person and that's all I really care
about like I want to I want to make sure
that these kids go as far as they can in
their personal lives and careers and
that's my priority I don't think that
the house would work without someone
like me I'm very entrepreneurial so like
I think of things that nobody else
thinks so every time you put a shirt on
every time you wear something a brand
you have to understand you're putting it
out there for the world every product
you buy everything you put a swipe up
for everything you promote you're losing
money these kids don't realize that I
want to see these kids get not get taken
advantage of I want to see them make the
money they deserve to be making and get
the recognition they deserve to get
that's my big focus I've always wanted
to do like a social media household ever
since my previous experiences with one
man took a lot of inspiration from teams
Hannah from Jake and then I just saw
where I could change it and tweak it and
turn it into something different a
little bit better in some ways when we
were focusing on building this up we
were focused on more of the family bond
more of the collaborative effort
[Music]
we want to be the PG version we want to
be the the Disney version the
Nickelodeon version we want to be the
positive that the people that are open
to everybody that don't hate anyone that
has is all about literally like it
sounds silly but just making a good
environment where everyone loves each
other no one here is signed to the hype
house like that's not a that's not a
thing we don't take a percentage of
anyone's careers but I feel like that's
where we're different and that's why we
have such a good bond and that's why
we're all such close friends and family
and we don't want to take a percentage
because it just it ruins a relationship
and that's where you get a lot of stuff
behind people's backs and like a lot of
people talking crap and all that and we
wanted to avoid that as best we could
I'll put myself out on deals that I'm
gonna go shooting for people so since I
have a social media following I make
more money on those deals than I would
taking 10% for everyone since I'm still
21 like I have I can still do it and get
those brand deals in don't need to take
a percentage for them which is just more
money for them and more money for me and
so just that's the way I do it how are
you gonna have the best lighting in the
entire house and you haven't used it
once I haven't encountered that really I
think that it's cuz I look older and I I
hold myself a lot older but most people
assume I'm 26 27 I like think that I've
been to college and I've done all this
and I've been in business but
realistically I didn't have a single
connection in LA two months ago
though outside of just social media kids
and now I know like some of the heads of
the biggest record labels in the world
and it's like it just happens really
fast when you put yourself out there I
started buying and selling products from
Alibaba and selling them to kids in
school when I was like 11 I went to
school a lot of rich kids and I wasn't
rich so I bought products and resold
them from a lot more like 10 times more
face me cover NIC we have a really good
eye for this stuff I reached out to
Addison when she had I think 12 K on
Instagram I reached out to Charlie and
she had like 6 K on Instagram chase
reached out to her when she had like
1015 k2 and that's how they became
friends in the first place back to death
I met Khalid a long time ago the artist
when he had like 5000 followers on
Instagram I was like hey man like
locations a great song I found it on
soundcloud and we became friends man I
feel like I just have a good ear and eye
for this stuff
being something different and now it's
about just remembering that if we bring
someone in with 20,000 followers that we
know we're gonna blow up to a million
they have to be loyal they have to bring
back that value if we're not going to
take 20% of their career they have to be
like promoting our product exactly doing
all that it's just about figuring all
that out before we bring in more people
we want everyone to be able to live
their life and date whoever they want to
date and whoever decides to be in a
relationship but you live your own life
just remember that it's when you involve
social media you're also putting
yourself out there and your partner out
there for a lot of people and it's their
lawyer they're gonna be watching out for
you they're gonna be watching out for
every little detail about your
relationship
I just recently started talking to
someone for the first time in a while I
had like a six year long relationship so
after that I didn't talk to anyone for a
while and then I'm just talking with a
girl we're seeing how it goes no no
normal person I think she likes it and
thinks it's really interesting and she
just kind of observes from a different
perspective which I appreciate because
it's like not she's not in this stuff
and she doesn't care about being a tick
talker a youtuber and that's something
that I really like because I don't want
someone to be involved in this industry
yeah 100% we have things that people
really want
we have followers we have a nice house
we have more money than some people and
like we I've I've worked my ass off to
get where I am today like I've been
working grindin since I was 12 years old
and been through hell and back to get
where I am today so I I don't really
open up to a lot of people in that way I
have 20 people that I've built around me
to trust that I know I have my back and
everything so I stick to those people
and then dating-wise I don't like to
reach out to anybody to try to do that
because it's just you know what they're
looking for most the time my goal is
just to set the standard for the future
of entertainment and for City social
media kids because there's no reason why
we can't be the next Kardashians there's
no reason why not like what do they have
that we don't have nothing there's no
difference they just marketed really
well and they killed it and they're
doing amazing there's no reason why we
can't do that become a household name
become the hype house could be known all
across the world that we could build it
out to build the hype house in New York
we could build a hype house in Europe
and we could do we could become an
actual brand that's known and has
worldwide recognition that for the
newest talent we're gonna have talent
scouts and we're gonna have people like
me come in and manage these houses and
it could be a real business they cannot
just be just a group of 20 tick talkers
that work together maybe I think it'd be
cool to see the how different like I
operate in this house versus how a lot
of the other people operate and that
there's a lot of drama that happens on a
daily basis we have a lot of stuff that
happens every day that we're yelling
about that people are arguing about it's
just that's just part of living with 10
20 people coming over the house every
day we just like to have the environment
where you're frustrated with something
yell about the person about it saying
why you're frustrated get it off your
chest let's fix it
move forward cuz that's the only way
it's gonna work I want to build out a
music label that's a big goal of mine
I want to partner with a big company
maybe Republic and build out my own my
own label and sign my own artists a year
from now getting into the music space a
little bit she's doing his own thing
he's that yeah he's doing his own thing
and that's what's amazing about this
place build up your career and then
eventually you go off and do your own
thing we're not trying to trap people
we're trying to provide an environment
that can help grow everyone and maybe
the music people are looking at us for
the next people and it's like maybe we
can just Scout people bring them in help
them make those connections and send
them off to keep coming continue with a
career I couldn't even tell you I don't
know where it's gonna be in six months
[Music]